Trong vòng hai bí từ giờ qua, khu vực trung đông trung kiến đợt léo thang nghiêm trọng nhất
giữa Isra Rain và Irang trong nhiều năm trở lại đây.
Với các cuộc tảnh công quân sự quy mồ lớn từ cả hai viếp.
Theo phòng viên thông tình sẽ Việt Nam tại trung đông và bắt phi.
Tối như Mỹ-Bặt Hằng Sau, Irang đã phòng loạt tên lửa xíu vừa đâm nhằm vào Isra Rain
nhằm đáp trả đón không tức trực đỏ của theo viếp.
Trong số các tên lửa được xưa giúp, có loại emét tầm bản mùi in mời trăm kêu mét,
kể bà sê càng một nằm trong kêu mét và gà đưa đặt tới hai gình kêu mét
đưa tình công ngày khiến ý nhất bà người thình mạo và hơn hai trong người bị thương tỷ Seren
không chục trễ, Isra Rain mở được phản công vào sáng 18,
nhằm vào hàng loạt tơ sợ của sử của Thé Rang trong đó có trụ sợ bụng cuo phòng Irang và hai khó dầu lớn
trong một đồng thải đáp trả mạnh mẹ hơn vào giảng sáng em, bởi lắm thằng sau
lưu gồm phải định kích bằng hồi dạo Irang, Irang, Irang, Sê Tinh bố,
thức hiện trên dịch lời hơi trên thật ba, sự dụng máy mấy khu ngủy lãi và tây lợi để tình công vào các
sợ sợ sợ sợ chiến lượng hàng không và chúng tâm năng lượng của Isra Rain,
tổng thủ Irang, Oma Sút, Tây Dí Scayan, Cạnh Bảo, Sê Cô Phản Nguyên Khá hơn,
Nếu Isra Rain không gần hành động của sử, trong bụng cạnh hàng của Isra Tân Cau,
vòng đàn phán hàng nhân dưới bị và Irang dự kiến dễ dàng ngày băm thằng sau tại Mù Scat, Oman gà bị hồi bỏ.
Mòa xe Oman bà đưa á bụxai đi xác nhận quyết định này trong khi phía Mỹ vật bầy tỏ mông mồn vì chỉ đổi thôi.
Một quan trức Mỹ dầu tiên cho biết, Washington vẫn hi vọng có thể tổ chức đàn phán bất chấp tình hình nhau thang.
Dịch bình mới cũng gây quần ai xấu sắc trong cố vực.
Giống đàn đau cửa công phận lượng thứ 2 lần tiết.
Y rắc tăng cường để phóng ở rao để tránh bị lôi kéo vào sử dụt.
Thái lan thì kéo vọa công dân về nước ngay là tức.
Chứ tình hình này như là đoạn của vực trong đồ của thái tự ở Rập xe Ut,
một hà mẹc biến sà măn đã tăng cường tiếp xúc ngoại rau trong cuối địa đàn ngày bí bụt thằng sau với tâm thằng Iran,
về chiến kia n hà mẹt kêu gọi giải quyết bất đồng bằng đổi thôi.
Ngà cũng vọc quốc với ngoại trường sẽ gửi lắp rốt khẳng định.
Mắt kêu và sất sàng nó vời cho chúng ra nhằm hạn như các thằng và nối lại đạm phản hạn nhận.